DEA says it will keep fighting the
opioid crisis and quote use all the
tools at our disposal to combat this
epidemic the healthcare distribution
Alliance representing the drug
distribution industry said the report
presented quote a misleading picture it
says distributors are quote strongly
committed to finding systemic solutions
to the challenges that contributed to
the opioid epidemic the Washington Post
health and medicine reporter Lenny
Bernstein co-authored his papers report
on the joint investigation with 16
minutes he joins us from Washington good
morning Lenny and incredible piece in
the post and on 60 minutes last night to
read the whole thing you talked to
former DEA agents including Jim Geldof
who was a 40-year DEA veteran who said
this was a business plan are these drug
distributors complicit in this epidemic
well there certainly have been caught
numerous times over and over and over
again not reporting suspicious orders of
these opioid pain pills from doctors and
pharmacies that is the law they must
report those things they must report
them to the DEA and say mm-hmm this guy
ordered 20,000 pills last month now he
wants a hundred thousand pills we're a
little worried about that over and over
and over again they did not do that and
those pills found their way into the
hands of users and dealers so then the
question becomes why did they not report
it right right is it because they want
to make money is it because it's too
difficult for them to keep track of all
these pills is it because they just were
not geared up to do this kind of due
diligence it doesn't really matter the
law is the law I can't just not report
my taxes because I have some reason that
that prohibits me from doing my taxes
you've got to do it they've got to find
a way to do it if those pills spill out
onto the street by the hundreds of
millions it's their responsibility this
bill was written by former DEA official
passed by unanimous consent of Congress
what was the argument that made that
happen the argument that made that
happen the argument that sold this bill
on Capitol Hill was that legitimate pill
users legitimate legitimate painkiller
users we're not getting their drugs in
an efficient manner and congressman
Moreno and others brought that to
Congress and said well I've got all
these folks out there who do need these
pills and they're not able to get them
when they need them because the DEA is
out of control because the DEA is
cracking down so hard on these
distributors that folks are not getting
their drugs well there's nothing in the
law that actually changes that at all
and the evidence for that was actually
sort of anecdotal where is the evidence
for the fact that these pills were
ending up at the hands of dealers and
users was quite substantial well any the
DEA told us that only a minut fraction
of the more than 1.7 million individuals
with DEA registrations are involved in
the inappropriate distribution of these
drugs how impactful is that fraction
well that's true but the impact that one
single pharmacy can have is enormous as
we reported and you at 60 minutes
reported you had a single pharmacy in
West Virginia that put millions of pills
on on the street in a town of several
hundred people there were two pharmacies
in Sanford Florida in the in the time
frame before 2012 that put millions of
pills on the street by themselves and
and the underground network gets to know
where these pharmacies are and people
come from far and wide from Appalachia
all the way down to Florida from Ohio
and they get those pills if you have a
rogue doctor or a rogue pharmacist the
impact is enormous what's been the
response to the piece about 60 minutes
on Sunday night and to the portion post
above the full lead story on Sunday well
we've heard from the DEA they issued the
statement that you guys referenced at
the beginning of this segment we've
heard from the drug distributors they
have made several arguments that are
true but irrelevant to our reporting and
you know it's Monday morning here we'll
see what happens on Capitol Hill but Tom
Marino is nominated to be the next drug
czar he is at least what do you think we
don't we don't know we don't know what
will happen there you know his hearing
isn't even set Lenny Bernstein with the
Washington Post great reporting thanks
Lenny